eu nunca antes na história vemos tão
perto de mudar existência da humanidade
e poucos anos fomos do analógico para o
digital
a dominamos a tecnologia como jamais
visto a nanotecnologia que melhora as
funções do corpo humano a biotecnologia
com a consequência mento do Genoma e a
criação de uma ferramenta capaz de mudar
o nosso DNA Já faz mais de duas décadas
têm Inteligência Artificial derrotou
Kasparov maior campeão de xadrez da
história Hoje ela está presente no robô
da 20 que faz cirurgias e agora estão
atrás de uma nova Inteligência
Artificial que é incrível e ao mesmo
tempo assustador que seria capaz de
sentir emoções
é ter consciência de si mesmo eu não vou
entrar no dilema dessa evolução os
perigos e ao mesmo tempo no avanço que
ela pode trazer para humanidade mas eu
vou chamar atenção Para uma das
características do ser humano que nunca
antes foi tão necessário esse ano de
2020 desafia exatamente nesse sentido a
humanidade dentro de cada um na simples
capacidade de cuidar eu sou médica em um
hospital geral e a partir da minha
experiência por conta duas histórias
adaptadas e convidam a pensar sobre essa
conexão entre o tempo e o cuidado
hoje era sexta-feira de manhã e como
todas as sextas-feiras carregada com
peso dos dias da semana em um sido um
paciente que tinha simulado uma doença
que causou graves consequências no seu
estado de saúde
e também no dia anterior tínhamos tido
uma das conversas mais difíceis sobre a
fim de vida toda equipe tinha sentido
peso daquela semana ela antes da
pandemia e podiam circular Pelo hospital
com as nossas roupas usuais de trabalho
sem máscara Um dos pacientes que estava
de alta naquela manhã era o senhor Paulo
67 anos hipertenso diabético o
insuficiência cardíaca e uma doença
arterial periférica
um grave e ocasionou a um cotação da
perna esquerda acima do joelho e há
menos de seis meses da perna direita
logo abaixo do joelho
o senhor Paulo havia chegado na nossa
equipe a 13 dias muito grave confuso
numa sexta-feira de tarde sem reconhecer
a própria filha Bibiana
e ele estava com muita falta de ar muita
dificuldade para respirar tinha perdido
a função dos rins que já não eram lá
essas coisas por conta do diabetes e da
hipertensão
e ele estava com líquidos acumulados em
todas as todas as partes do corpo
inclusive nos pulmões em risco de entrar
em insuficiência respiratória se algo
não fosse feito muito rapidamente a
residente que estava responsável por Ele
prontamente identificou a gravidade do
quadro acionou a equipe da nefrologia e
conseguiu que ele fosse a hemodiálise
naquela mesma noite o processo não tão
simples nem direto no dia seguinte ele
estava um pouco melhor menos confuso
respirando mais tranquilamente mas ainda
assim muito grave
e na segunda-feira na troca das equipes
o residente que ficou responsável por
Ele identificou uma alteração nas
células brancas do sangue do Senhor
Paulo havia um aumento muito expressivos
um tipo específico de célula ele iniciou
uma investigação e acabou por descobrir
uma leucemia para ele uma outra história
a comunicação desse diagnóstico do São
Paulo e para sua família mas isso fica
para outro momento
e ele evoluiu bem recuperou parcialmente
a função dos rins a conta de não
precisar mais da hemodiálise e ele
estava de alta naquela manhã então
chegamos para fazer a visita nos
posicionamos ao redor do leite ele no
centro na cama os contos das pernas
amputadas visíveis no seu lado direito a
sua filha Viviane do seu lado esquerdo
do seu sobrinho Lucas ele estava muito
feliz por poder ir para casa contente
mesmo por ter conseguido controlar todas
as complicações tirou suas dúvidas serão
as perguntas que achava que tinha que
fazer e se sentiu tão à vontade que
contou a seguinte piada
eu chego Doutor para falar com o
paciente tenho duas notícias para lhe
dar uma boa e uma ruim Qual o senhor
quero ouvir o primeiro e vai sente disso
primeira ruim né Doutor depois a gente
dá aquela amaciada com a boa é isso pois
bem
O ruim é que o senhor vai ter que
amputar as duas pernas
e as duas e qual seria boto à boi tem um
rapaz lá na portaria que quer comprar o
seu tênis até enfermeira que tava no
leito ao lado do rio na verdade todos
rimos na enfermaria ter essa capacidade
de Despertar a alegria através do Riso
Depois de tanto sofrimento gera um
sentimento tão potente e faz a gente
entender que a vida é muito mais do que
as dificuldades os impedimentos o as
limitações
e sem querer o seu Paulo naquele momento
cuidou mais da gente do que nós dele
agora segunda história é no momento mais
recente quase no pico da academia eu
tava de plantão 12 horas no domingo e
entre uma descida emergência trabalhar
um paciente o procedimento para pegar a
ver em outro eu sou chamada pela
residente que estava de plantão junto
comigo para avaliar Mussum caso juntos
e a se registrar é o primeiro ano dela
como o médico e em seu justo no ano no
mês da chegada da academia mas ela é
daquelas que rapidamente pega o ritmo
atenta interessada Responsável a
enfermeira via chamada para gente
avaliar um paciente que estava com muita
dificuldade para respirar ele tinha
internado há vários dias para tratar uma
pneumonia 71 anos e um câncer de mama
que o acompanha há sete anos agora com
metástases nos pulmões no fígado e nos
ossos já fez todos os tratamentos
possíveis isso oncologistas Disseram que
ele não tem mais condições de fazer
nenhuma outra quimioterapia e nem ele
quer mais fazer nenhum tratamento mais
agressivo
e já na chegada ao quarto quando
entramos onde ficam alojadas 13
pacientes encontramos a filha aos pés da
cama atenta nos aproximamos e pela
direita residente pela esquerda já não
podemos mais fazer cm círculos ao redor
do leito estamos assim usando máscaras o
tempo todo escudos eu chego perto chama
pelo nome ele ofegante atrás da máscara
de oxigênio abre os olhos eu pergunto
como o senhor está e ele responde
cansado eu pergunto com falta de ar ele
disse um pouco melhor com o oxigênio
e enquanto eu examino pergunta para
filho aqui tem mais alguém da família
que te ajuda a cuidar dele aqui e ela
responde mais um irmão uma irmã EA mãe
termino de examiná-lo e digo que vou
olhar os exames para voltar depois
decidimos que a gente vai fazer
e quando eu abro o raio x eu levo um
susto parecem alterações da corrente a
presidente também ficou preocupadas
e ele não tinha critério de síndrome
gripal mas ele teve febre e tem aquelas
alterações nesse momento passa pela
minha cabeça as implicações dos próximos
passos ele vai ter que sair daquele
quarto ficar isolado cuida tá pesquisa
do Corona e seguindo a regra ficar
sozinho
eu chego pensar alto com a residente não
quero tirar perto dos filhos eu não vou
tirar deve-se corrigir acho que não mas
aí eu olho para o rosto da jovem médica
e penso que por mais compaixão que
possamos ser por ele nesse momento não
podemos fingir que não tem essa
possibilidade
O que é o correto a fazer então Voltamos
ao ar e conversamos com ele com a filho
explicamos que por ter ficado rápido
pelas alterações o raio X por ele ter
tido febre é possível que você a gente
ficado com o vírus Para isso precisamos
trocaram de lugar e ele vai ter que
ficar isolado
e ele eles entendem eo transporte o
penso comigo eu acho que ele não vai
melhorar
ó e vai ter que ficar longe da família e
ainda se confirmar o convide ele não vai
nem poder ter velório
eu peço para falar com os outros filhos
e não é tão fácil assim tempo de
pandemia achar uma família para falar
Preciso algumas autorizações
e eu como médica do plantão conheço
praticamente nada dessa família estou
olhando para uma janela de vida desse
Senhor
é mas eu consigo que eles venham E eles
vêm prontamente para o hospital então
converso com eles
eu cai nesse momento dos meus vamos
nossos ombros a residente sempre teve
comigo Carlos nossos ombros uma certa
cresce para atender a tantas outras
demandas do plantão o que tende a nos
forçar a ser rápidas e passar logo as
informações para eles a se tivesse uns
tempo para poder ter essas conversas
É mas eu não me sinto confortável em
fazer isso não seria correto e eu
terminaria o plantão sabendo que não fiz
direito assim mesmo tempo sendo cor eu
escolho escolher escutá-los com atenção
para tentar me conectar entender um
pouco melhor Quem é esse senhor de 71
anos e relações ele tem com essa família
para só então poder dizer o que eu
preciso dizer tentar conduzi-los nesse
entendimento do final da vida essa
família precisa entender não só faz
deles está indo mas também todas as
implicações que a inter alguém da
família com convide as recomendações os
cuidados é muita coisa para processar
como fazer isso sem dar tempo a eles
quanto tempo
eu acho que uma das coisas que ajuda a
gente ia mudar a forma como percebemos o
tempo nesses momentos é o quanto
realmente conseguimos nos conectar com a
situação
e eu converso com a enfermeira da
unidade convite ela também não não não
conhece mas explico para ela a situação
e ela da mesma forma se sensibiliza
assim seguindo a regra conseguimos que
cada um dos filhos pudesse ter o seu
momento com o pai enquanto ele ainda tem
consciência
eu ajudei os a vestidos jalecos ensinei
os a lavarem as mãos e abrir a porta do
quarto para que cada um pudesse ter o
seu momento um por vez a sua maneira sem
tirar a legitimidade que o sofrimento
que o câncer esse para o qual o
tratamento já se esgotaram trás
e vem a oportunidade o a possibilidade
de repensar mos o que faz sentido na
vida
e me a chance de escolher uns as nossas
melhores palavras de pedir desculpas que
acertar os ponteiros me desculpar e
dizer o quanto aquela vida segue apesar
do relógio parar de contar os segundos
para ela
o meu plantão Terminou as 20 horas
daquela noite ficando a terceira filha
com ele no quarto no final do dia
seguinte
e eu escrevi para Residente vi que o
nome dele não tá mais na lista de
internados no hospital e ela respondeu
positivou e faleceu e bom tivemos tempo
para conversar o tempo pode ser medido
em janelas os sete anos do Câncer 71
anos de vida às doze horas do plantão do
1º ano da residência os instantes do iso
provocado os minutos com cada filho
e o cuidado que damos ou recebemos
nessas janelas independe do tempo e ao
que prova Nossa humanidade já tal
Inteligência Artificial forte lá do
início dessa fala será que a frase desse
tipo de cuidado eu não sei mas usando as
palavras da ativista americana Maya
angelu eu posso dizer que as pessoas
elas não vão se lembrar que você diz
elas não vão se lembrar do que você fez
mas elas vão se lembrar de como você as
fez sentir um